a sudden calm outside for a moment no
soldiers just us alone with hundreds
seeking refuge
well not quite alone
the taliban are doing security
every day this place gets stranger and
stranger
amongst the crowd british passport
holders waving to us unable to come
forward told to stay where they are
there are lots of british nationals and
residents and europeans as well here
waiting for their turn inside
they've taken days to get to the gates
many have the paperwork they all say
it's been absolutely horrendous and
dangerous
i've been stuck here for the past two
days i'm trying to get in i went to the
americans they pushed me out they kicked
me out i went to the germans they beat
me out with the sticks they fired us
you see these uh gas fires that they
make you cry yeah take us yeah
and everyone was crying right here like
an hour ago
the tear gas in between the kids you see
the kids they're like one years old kid
how can you put it the americans is that
the american
the americans the germans they're too
rude they beat our people with baseball
bats
while the british soldiers are trying to
deal with large numbers of uk nationals
and people cleared to come to britain
they've also taken in hundreds who
should be at the american base not here
getting them to the right place is a
logistical nightmare protecting them and
the base from being overrun is hard
the paris form into a defensive square
trying to keep the crowds calm urging
people to sit
all ages are here all confused tired
upset and desperate
[Music]
for now at least the british relief
effort has to pause to let the american
relief effort continue well the crowds
have got so close now
um that the um soldiers have to form
basically a square
um to get from one compound to another
they're taking out civilians and uh
they've trying to keep everyone calm
those of them have got the right to come
inside but at the moment they can't very
very tense here very very tense because
these people are desperate
in single file the evacuees heading to
america are brought from one camp and
directed to another
family is attempting to escape the new
taliban emirate of afghanistan
there are always so many children
hopefully they're too young to know what
an earth is going on
children too amongst the crowds at the
moment blocked from entry into the place
that could be the gateway to a new life
or if they're british their rightful
home
from the compound a helicopter lifts off
ferrying the refugees to the military
airport their next step on the journey
to freedom from the taliban